what is up everybody today you're gonna
learn how to go from a paper to a fully
functional implementation of deep
deterministic policy gradients if you're
not familiar with deep deterministic
Balaji gradients or DD PG for short it
is a type of deep reinforcement learning
that is used in environments from the
continuous action spaces
you see most environments have discrete
action spaces this is the case with say
the Atari library say like breakout or
space invaders where the edge you can
move left right it can shoot but it can
move left right and shoot by fixed
discrete intervals fixed amounts right
in other environments like say robotics
the robots can move a continuous amount
so it can move in anywhere from you know
a zero to one minus one to plus one
anything along a continuous number
interval and this poses a problem for
most deep reinforcement learning methods
like say q-learning which works
spectacularly well in discrete
environments but cannot tackle
continuous action spaces now if you
don't know what any of this means don't
worry I'm going to give you the rundown
here in a second but for this set of
tutorials you're gonna need to have
installed the open AI gym you'll need
Python 3.6 and you also need tensorflow
and pi torch other packages you'll need
include MATLAB to handle the plotting of
the learning curve which will allow us
to see the actual learning of the agent
as well as numpy to handle your typical
vector operations now here I'll give you
a quick little rundown of reinforcement
learning so the basic idea is that we
have an agent that interacts with some
environment and receives a reward the
rewards kind of take the place of labels
and supervised learning in that they
tell the agent what is good what is it
that it is shooting for in the
environment and so the agent will
attempt to maximize the total rewards
over time by solving something known as
the bellman equation we don't have to
worry about the actual mathematics of it
but just so you know for your future
research the algorithms are typically
concerned with solving the bellman
equation which tells the agent the
expected feature returns assuming to
follow something called it's policy so
the policy is the probability that the
agent will take a set of actions given
it's in some state s it's basically a
probability distribution
now many types of algorithms such
q-learning will attempt to solve the
bellman equation by finding what's
called the value function the value
function or the action value function in
this case map's the current state and
set of possible actions to the expected
feature returns the agent expects to
receive so in other words the agent says
hey I'm in some state meaning some
configuration of pixels on the screen in
the case of the Atari gym Atari library
for instance and says okay if I take one
or another action what is the expected
feature return assuming that I follow my
policy after critic methods are slightly
different and then they attempt to learn
the policy directly and recall the
policy is a probability distribution
that tells the agent what the
probability of selecting an action is
given it's in some state s so these two
algorithms have a number of strengths
between them and deterministic policy
gradients is a way to marry the
strengths of these two algorithms into
something that does really well for
discrete actions sorry continuous action
spaces you don't need to know too much
more than that everything else you need
to know I'll explain in their respective
videos so in the first video you're
gonna get to see how I go ahead and read
papers and then implement them on the
fly and in the second video you're gonna
see the implementation of deep
deterministic policy gradients in Pytor
in a separate environment both of these
environments are in both of these
environments are continuous and so they
will demonstrate the power of the
algorithm quite nicely you don't need a
particularly powerful GPU but you do
need some kind of GPU to run these as it
does take a considerably long time even
on a GPU so you will need at least a
like say a maximal class GPU or above so
something from the 700 series on NVIDIA
side unfortunately neither of these
frameworks really work well with AMD
cards so if you have those you'd have to
figure out some sort of Cluj to get the
OpenCL implementation to trance compiled
to CUDA that's just a technical detail I
don't have any information on that so
you're on your own sorry so this is a
few hours of content grab a snack drink
and watch this at your leisure it's best
to watch it in order I'd actually did
the videos in a separate order
reverse order on my channel just so I
could get it out so I did the
implementation in PI tours first and
then the video on implementing the paper
in tensor flow second but it really is
best for a new audience to go from the
paper paper video to the PI torch video
so I hope you like it leave it in the
comments questions suggestions issues
down below I'll try to address as many
as possible you can check out the code
for this on my github and you can find
many more videos like this all my
youtube channel machine learning with
Phil I hope you all enjoy it let's get
to it what is up everybody in today's
video we're gonna go from the paper on
deep deterministic policy gradients all
the way into a functional implementation
in tensor flow so you're gonna see how
to go from a paper to a real-world
implementation all in one video grab a
snack a drink cuz this is gonna take a
while
let's get started
so the first step in my process really
isn't anything special I just read the
entirety of the paper of course starting
with the abstract the abstract tells you
what the paper is about at a high level
it's just kind of an executive summary
introduction is where the author's will
pay homage to other work in the field
kind of set the stage for what is going
to be presented in the paper as well as
the need for it the background kind of
expands on that and you can see here it
gives us a little bit of mathematical
equations and you will get a lot of
useful information here this won't talk
too much about useful nuggets on
implementation but it does set the stage
for the mathematics you're going to be
implementing which is of course critical
for any deep learning or in this case
deep reinforcement learning paper
implementation the algorithm is really
where all the meat of the problem is it
is in here and that they lay out the
exact steps you need to take to
implement the algorithm right that's why
it's titled that way so this is the
section we want to read most carefully
and then of course they will typically
give a table where they outline the
actual algorithm and oftentimes if I'm
in a hurry I will just jump to this
because I've done this enough times that
I can read this what it's called
pseudocode if you're not familiar with
the pseudocode it's just an English
representation of computer code so we
will typically use that when we outline
a problem and it's often used in papers
of course so typically I'll start here
reading it and then work backward by
reading through the paper to see what I
missed but of course it talks about the
performance across a whole host of
environments and of course all of these
have in common that they are continuous
control so what that means is that the
action space is a vector whose elements
can vary on a continuous real number
line instead of having discrete actions
of zero one two three four or five so
that is the really motivation behind
deep deterministic policy gradients is
that allows us to use deep reinforcement
learning to tackle these types of
problems and in today's video we're
gonna go ahead and tackle the I guess
pendulum swing up also called
pendulum problem reason being is that
while it would be awesome to start out
with something like the bipedal Walker
you never want to start out with maximum
complexity you always want to start out
with something very very small and then
scale your way up and the reason is that
you're going to make mistakes and it's
most easy to debug most quick to debug
very simple environments that execute
very quickly so the pendulum problem
only has I think three elements in its
state vector and only a single action so
or maybe it's two actions I forget but
either way it's very small problem
relative to something like the bipedal
Walker or many of the other environments
you could also use the continuous
version of the cart pole or something
like that and that would be perfectly
fine I've just chosen the pendulum for
this particular video because we haven't
done it before so it's in here that they
give a bunch of plots of all of the
performance of their algorithm of the
various sets of constraints placed upon
it and different implementations so you
can get an idea and one thing you notice
right away it's always important to look
at plots because they give you a lot of
information visually right it's much
easier to gather information from plots
than it is text you see that right away
they have a scale of 1 so that's telling
you it's relative performance and you
have to read the paper to know relative
to what I don't like that particular
approach they have similar data in a
table form and here you see a whole
bunch of environments they used and
there's a broad broad variety they
wanted to show that the algorithm has a
wide arena of applicability which is a
typical technique and papers they want
to show that this is relevant right if
they only showed a single environment
people reading it would say well that's
all well and good you can solve one
environment but what about these dozen
other environments right and part of the
motivation behind reinforcement learning
is generality can as can we model real
learning and biological systems such
that it mimics the generality of
biological learning one thing you notice
right away is that these numbers are not
actual scores so that's one thing I kind
of take note of and causes me to raise
an eyebrow so you have to wonder the
motivation behind that why would the
authors express scores in a ratio
there's a couple different reasons one
is because they want
- just to make all the numbers look
uniform maybe the people reading the
paper wouldn't be familiar with each of
these environment so they don't know
what a good score is and that's a
perfectly valid reason and other
possibilities they want to hide poor
performance I don't think that's going
on here but it does make me raise my
eyebrow whenever I see it the one
exception is the torques which is a
totally open rate race car simulator
environment I don't know if we'll get to
that on this channel that would be a
pretty cool project but that would take
me a few weeks to get through but right
away you notice that they have a whole
bunch of environments these scores are
all relative to one and one is the score
that the agent gets on a planning
algorithm which they also detail later
on so those are the results and they
talk more about I don't think we saw the
headline but they talk about related
work which talks about other algorithms
that are similar and their shortcomings
right they don't ever want to talk up
other algorithms you always want to talk
up your own algorithm to make yourself
sound good you know why else did you be
writing a paper in the first place
and of course our concluding that's high
everything together references I don't
usually go deep into references if there
is something that I feel I really really
need to know I may look at a reference
but I don't typically bother with them
if you were a PhD student then it would
behoove you to go into the references
because you must be an absolute expert
on the topic and for us we're just you
know hobbyists I'm a youtuber so I don't
go into too much depth with the
background information and the next most
important bit of the paper are the
experimental details and it is in here
that it gives us the parameters and
architectures for the network's
so this is where if you saw my previous
video where I did the implementation of
DD PG and PI torch and the continuous
lunar lander environment this is where I
got most of this stuff it was almost
identical with a little bit of tweaking
I left out some stuff from this paper
but pretty much all of it came from here
and particularly the hidden layer sizes
400 and 300 units as well as the
initialization of the parameters from
a uniform distribution of the given
ranges so just to recap this was a
really quick overview of the paper just
showing my process of what I look at the
most important parts are the details of
the algorithm as well as the
experimental details so as you read the
paper like I said I gloss over the
introduction because I don't really I
kind of already understand the
motivation behind it I get the idea
it says it basically tells us that you
can't really handle mmm
just continuous action spaces with DQ
networks we already know that and it
says you know you can discretize the
state space but then you end up with
really really huge actions sorry you can
discretize the action space but then you
end up with the you know whole boatload
of actions you know what is it 2187
action so it's intractable anyway and
they say what we present you know a
model free of policy algorithm and then
it comes down to this section where it
says the network is trained off policy
with samples from a replay buffer to
minimize correlations very good and
train with the target Q network to give
consistent targets during temporal
difference backups so this work we make
use of the same ideas along with a batch
normalization so this is a key chunk of
text and this is why you want to read
the whole paper because sometimes
they'll embed stuff in there that you
may not otherwise catch so as I'm
reading the paper what I do is I take
notes and you can do this in paper you
can do it in you know text document in
this case we reading is the editor so
that way I can show you what's going on
and it's a natural place to put this
stuff because that's where you can
implement the code anyway let's hop over
to the editor and you'll see what I take
notes so right off the bat we always
want to be thinking in terms of what
sort of classes and functions will we
need to implement this algorithm so the
paper mentioned a replay buffer as well
as a target queue network so the target
queue network for now we don't really
know what it's going to be but we can
write it down so we'll say we'll need a
replay buffer class
and need a class for a target hue
Network now I would assume that if you
were going to be implementing a paper of
this advanced difficulty you'd already
be familiar with cue learning where you
know that the target network is just
another instance of a generalized
network the difference between the
target and evaluation networks are you
know the way in which you update their
weights so right off the bat we know
that we're gonna have a single class at
least one if you know something about
actor critic methods you'll know that
you'll probably have two different
classes one for an actor one for a
critic because those two architectures
are generally a little bit different but
what do we know about cue networks we
know that cue networks are state action
value functions right they're not just
value functions so the critic in the
actor critic methods is just a state
value function in general whereas here
we have a cue network which is going to
be a function of the state in action so
we know that it's a function of s and a
so we know right off the bat it's not
the same as a critic it's a little bit
different and it also said we we will
use we will use batch norm so a batch
normalization is just a way of
normalizing inputs to prevent divergence
and a model I think it was discovered in
2015 2014 something like that
so that we use that so we'll need that
in our network so we know at least two
right off the bat a little bit of an
idea of what the network is going to
look like so let's go back to the paper
and see what other little bits of
information we can glean from the text
before we take a look at the algorithm
reading along we can say blah blah they
say a key feature of simplicity it
requires only a straightforward actor
critic architecture and very few moving
parts and then they talk it up and say
can learn policies that exceed the
performance of the planner you know the
planning algorithm even learning from
pixels which we won't get to in this
particular implementation so then okay
no real other Nuggets there
the background talks about the
mathematical structure of the algorithm
so this is really important if you want
to have a really deep in-depth knowledge
of the topic if you already know enough
about the background you would know that
you know the formula for discounted
future rewards you should know that if
you've done a whole bunch of
reinforcement learning algorithms if you
haven't then definitely read through
this section to get the full idea of the
background and the motivation behind the
mathematics other thing to note is it
says the action value function is used
in many algorithms we know that from
deep Q learning and then it talks about
the recursive relationship known as the
bellman equation that is known as well
other thing to note what's interesting
here and this is the next nugget is if
the target policy is deterministic we
can describe as a function mu and so you
see that in the remainder of the paper
like in the algorithm they do indeed
make use of this parameter mu so that
tells us right off the bat that our
policy is going to be deterministic now
if you have you could probably guess
that from the title right D to turn is
deep deterministic policy gradients
right so you would guess from the name
that the policy is deterministic but
what does that mean exactly so a
stochastic policy is one in which the
software map's the probability of taking
an action to a given state so you input
a set of state and outcomes a
probability of selecting an action and
you select an action according to that
probability distribution so that right
away bakes in a solution to the explore
exploit dilemma so long as all
probabilities are finite right so so as
long as a probability of taking an
action for all states doesn't go to zero
there is some element of exploration
involved in that algorithm hew learning
handles the explore exploit dilemma by
using Epsilon greedy action selection
where you have a random parameter that
tells you how often to select a random
number
sorryi random action and then you select
a greedy action the remainder of the
time of course policy gradients don't
work that way they typically use a
stochastic policy but in this case we
have a deterministic policy so you've
got to wonder right away
okay we have a deterministic policy how
are we gonna handle the Explorer exploit
dilemma so let's go back to our text
editor and make a note of that so we
just want to say that the the policy is
deterministic how to handle Explorer
exploit and that's a critical question
right because if you only take what are
perceived as the greedy actions you
never get a really good coverage of the
parameter space of the problem and
you're going to converge on a suboptimal
strategy so this is a critical question
we have to answer in the paper so let's
head back to the paper and see how they
handle it so we're back in the paper and
you can see the reason they introduced
that deterministic policy is to avoid an
inner expectation or maybe that's just a
byproduct I guess it's not accurate to
say that's the reason they do it but
what's neat is says the expectation
depends only on the environment means
it's possible to learn Q to the MU
meaning Q is a function mu off policy
using transitions which are generated
from a different stochastic policy beta
so right there we have off policy
learning which they say explicitly with
a stochastic policy so we are actually
going to have two different policies in
this case so then this already answers
the question of how we go from a
deterministic policy to solving these
sports boy dilemma and the reason is
that we're using a stochastic policy to
learn the greedy policy or a sorry a
purely deterministic policy and of
course they talk about the parallels
with Q learning because there are many
between the two algorithms and you get
to the loss function which is of course
critical to the algorithm and this Y of
T parameter then of course they talk
about what Q learning has been used for
they use they make mention of deep
neural networks which is of course what
we're going to be using that's where the
deep comes from and talks about the car
Atari games which we've talked about on
this channel as well and importantly
they say the the two changes that they
introduce in Q learning which is the
concept of the replay buffer and that's
the target Network which of course they
already mentioned before they're just
reiterating and reinforcing what they
said that's why we want to read the
introduction
and background time material to get a
solid idea what's gonna happen so now we
get to the algorithmic portion and this
is where all of the magic happens so
they again reiterate that it's not
possible to apply q-learning to
continuous action spaces because you
know reasons right it's pretty obvious
you have an infinite number of actions
that's a problem and then they talk
about the deterministic policy gradient
algorithm which we're not going to go
too deep into right it for this video we
don't want to do the full thesis we
don't want to do a full doctoral
dissertation on the field we just want
to know how to implement it and get
moving
so this goes through and gives you an
update for the gradient of this
parameter J and gives it in terms of the
gradient of Q which is the state action
value function and the gradient of the
policy the deterministic policy mu other
thing to note here is that this
gradients these gradings are over two
different parameters so the gradient of
Q is with respect to the actions such
that the action a equals mu of s of T so
what this tells you is that Q is
actually a function not just of the
state but is intimately related to that
policy muse so it's not it's not an
action chosen according to an Arg max
for instance it's an action short chosen
according to the output of the other
Network and for the update of mu it's
just the gradient with respect to the
weights which you would kind of expect
so they talk about another algorithm and
fqc a I don't know what that is honestly
mini-batch version blah-de-blah
our contribution here is to provide
modifications a dbg inspired by the
success of DQ n which allowed to use
neural network function approximate is
to learn in large state in action spaces
online we call DD PG very creative as
they say again we use a replay buffer to
address the issues of correlations
between samples generated on subsequent
steps within an episode
finite size cache size our transition
sample from the environment so we know
all of this so if you don't know all of
it what you need to know here is that
you have state action reward and then
new state transitions so what this tells
the agent is started in some state s
took some action receive some reward and
ended up in some new state why is it
important it's important because in in
anything that isn't dynamic programming
you're really trying to learn the state
probability distributions you're trying
to learn the probability of going from
one state to another and receiving some
reward along the way if you knew all of
those beforehand then you could just
simply solve a set a very very large set
of equations for that matter to arrive
at the optimal solution right if you
knew all those transitions you say ok if
I start in this state and take some
action I'm gonna end up in some other
state with certainty then you'd say well
what's the most advantageous state what
state is going to give me the largest
reward and so you could kind of
construct some sort of algorithm for
traversing that set of equations to
maximize your reward over time now of
course you often don't know that and
that's the point of the replay buffer is
to learn that through experience and
interacting with the environment and it
says when the replay buffer was full all
the samples were discarded ok that makes
sense it's finite size it doesn't grow
indefinitely at each time step actor and
critic are updated by sampling a mini
batch uniformly from the buffer so it
operates exactly according to queue
learning it does a uniform sampling
Brandin sampling of the buffer and uses
that to update the actor and critic
networks what's critical here is that
combining this statement with the topic
of the previous paragraph is that when
we write our replay buffer class it must
sample states had random so what that
means is you don't want to sample a
sequence of subsequent steps and the
reason is that there are large
correlations between those steps right
as you might imagine and those
correlations can cause you to get
trapped in little nicks nooks and
crannies of parameter space and really
cause your algorithm to go wonky so you
want to sample that uniformly so that
way you're sampling across many many
different episodes to get a really good
idea of
the I guess the breath of the parameter
space to use kind of loose language and
then it says directly implementing
q-learning with neural networks approve
the unstable many environments and
they're they're gonna talk about using
the the target Network okay but modified
for actor critic using soft target
updates rather than directly copying the
weight so in q-learning we directly copy
the weights from the evaluation to the
target Network here it says we create a
copy of the actor and critic networks Q
prime and mu prime respectively that are
used for calculating the target values
the weights of these target networks are
then updated by having them slowly track
the learned networks theta prime goes to
theta theta times tau plus one minus tau
times theta prime with town much much
less than one this means that the target
values are constrained to change slowly
greatly improving the stability of
learning okay so this is our next little
nugget so let's head it over to the
paper and make to our text editor and
make note of that what we read was that
the we have to not in camps we don't
want to shout we have two networks
target networks sorry we have two actor
and two critic networks a target for
each updates are soft
according to theta equals tau times
theta plus one minus tau times theta
Prime
so I'm sorry there should be theta Prime
so this is the update rule for the
parameters of our target networks and we
have to target networks one for the
actor and one for the critic so we have
a total of four deep neural networks and
so this is why the algorithm runs so
slowly even on my beastly rig it runs
quite slowly even in the lunar lander in
a continuous lunar lander environment
I've done the bipedal Walker and it took
about 20,000 games to get something that
approximates a decent score so this is a
very very slow algorithm and that 20,000
games took I think about a day to run so
quite slow but nonetheless quite
powerful it's only method we have so far
I've implementing deep reinforcement
learning and continuous control
environments so hey you know beggars
can't be choosers right but we know just
to recap that we're gonna use four
networks two of it are on policy in two
off policy and the updates are gonna be
soft with with Towe much less than one
if you're not familiar with mathematics
this double less than or double
greater-than sign means much less than
or much greater then respectively so
what that means is that towel is gonna
be of order point zero one or smaller
right point one isn't much smaller
that's kind of smaller point zero one I
would consider much smaller they use
we'll see in the in the details we'll
see what value they use but you should
know that it's a order point zero one or
smaller and the reason they do this is
to allow the updates to happen very
slowly to get good convergence as they
said in the paper so let's head back to
the paper and see what other nuggets we
can clean before getting to the outline
of the algorithm and then in the very
next sentence they say this simple
change moves the relative unstable
problem of learning the action by a
function closer to the case of
supervised learning a problem for which
a robust solution exists we found that
having both the target Miu Prime and Q
problem was required to have stable
targets weii in order to consistently
train the critic with out divergence
this may slow learning since the target
networks delay the propagation of value
estimates however in practice we found
this was always
greatly outweighed by the stability of
learning and I found that as well you
don't get a whole lot of diversions but
it does take a while to train then they
talk about learning in low dimensional
and higher dimensional environments and
they do that to talk about the need for
feature scaling so one approach to the
problem which is the ranges of
variations in parameters right so in
different environments like in the
mountain car you can go from plus minus
one point six five minus one point six
to zero point four something like that
and the velocities are plus and minus
point zero seven so you have a two order
magnitude variation there and the
parameters that's kind of large even in
that environment and then when you
compare that to other environments where
you can have parameters that are much
larger on the order of hundreds you can
see that there's a pretty big issue with
the scaling of the inputs to the neural
network which we know from our
experience that neural networks are
highly sensitive to the scaling between
inputs so so their solution that problem
is to manually scale the features so
they're in similar across environments
and units and they do that by using
batch normalization and it says this
technique normalizes each dimension
across the samples in a mini batch dev
unit mean and variance and it also
maintains a running average of the mean
and variance used for normalization
during testing during exploration and
evaluation so in our case training and
testing are slightly different than in
the case of supervised learning so the
supervised learning you maintain
different data sets or shuffled subsets
of a single data set to do training and
evaluation and of course in the
evaluation phase you perform no weight
updates of the network you just see how
it does based on the training and
reinforcement learning you can do
something similar where you have a set
number of games where you train the
agent to achieve some set of results and
then you turn off the learning and allow
it to just choose actions based upon
whatever policy it learns and if you're
using batch normalization in PI torch in
particular there are significant
differences in how batch normalization
is used in the two different phases so
you have to be explicit in
setting training or evaluation mode in
particular in pi torch they don't track
statistics in evaluation mode which is
why when we wrote the DDP G algorithm in
PI torch we had to call the eval and
train functions so often okay so we've
already established will need batch
normalization so everything's kind of
starting to come together we need a
replay Network back to normalization we
need for networks right we need to we
need to each of a target of an actor
into each of eight critic so half of
those are gonna be used for on policy
now of them are going to be used for off
policy for the targets and then it says
will be scrolled down a major challenge
of learning and continuous action spaces
is exploration an advantage of off
policy algorithms such as DDP G is that
we can treat the problem of exploration
independently from the learning
algorithm we constructed an exploration
policy mu prime by adding noise sampled
from a noise process and to our actor
policy okay so right here is telling us
what the basically the target actor
function is it's mu prime is basically
mu plus some noise and n can be chosen
to suit the environment as detailed in
the supplementary materials we used in
Ornstein uhlenbeck process to generate
temporally correlated exploration for
exploration efficiency and physical
control problems with inertia if you're
not familiar face in Ursa just means the
tendency of stuff to stay in motion it
has to do with like environments that
move like the walkers the Cheetahs stuff
like that the ants
okay so we've kind of got one of them
nugget to add to our text editor let's
head back over there and write that down
okay so the target actor is just the
evaluation we'll call it that for lack
of a better word evaluation actor plus
some noise process they used Ornstein
kuhlenbeck I don't think I spelled that
correctly
we'll need to look that up that I've
already looked it up my background is in
physics so it made sense to me it's
basically a noise process that models
the motion of Brownian particles which
are just particles that move around
under the influence of their interaction
with other particles in some type of
medium like losses meeting like a
perfect food or something like that and
in the Ornstein in that case they are
temporally correlated meaning at each
time step is related to the time step
prior to it and I hadn't thought about
it before but that's probably important
for the case of Markov decision
processes right so in MVPs the current
state is only related to the prior state
and the action taken you don't need to
know the full history of the environment
so I wonder if that was chosen that way
if there's some underlying physical
reason for that just kind of a question
of gross female top of my head I don't
know the answer to that if someone knows
pipe drop the answer in the comments I
would be very curious to see the answer
so we have enough Nuggets here so just
to summarize we need to replay buffer
class will also need a class for the
noise right so we'll need a class for
noise a class for the replay buffer
we'll need a class for the target Q
Network and we're going to use batch
normalization the policy will be
deterministic so what that means in
practice is that the policy will output
the actual actions instead of the
probability of selecting the actions so
the policy will be limited by whatever
the action space of the environment is
so we need some way of taking that into
account so so deterministic policy means
outputs the actual action instead
of a probability we'll need a way to
bound the actions to the environment
environment limits and of course these
notes don't make it into the final code
these are just kind of things you think
of as you are reading the paper you
would want to put all your questions
here I don't have questions since I've
already implemented it but this is kind
of my thought process as I went through
it the first time as best as I can model
it after having finished the problem and
you can also use a sheet of paper
there's some kind of magic about writing
stuff down on paper but we're gonna use
the code editor because I don't want to
use an overhead projector to show you
guys a frigging sheet of paper this
isn't grade school here so let's head
back to the paper and take a look and
the actual algorithm to get some real
sense of what we're going to be
implementing the the results really
aren't super important to us yet we will
use that later on if we want to debug
the model performance but the fact that
they express it relative it to a
planning our that makes it difficult
right so scroll down to the data really
quick so they give another thing to note
I didn't talk about this earlier but I
guess now is a good time is the
stipulations on this turn on this
performance data says performance after
training across all environments for at
most 2.5 million steps so I said earlier
I had to train the bipedal walker for
around 20,000 games that's around times
I think that's around about about two
and a half million steps or so I think
it was actually have 15,000 steps so
maybe around three million steps
something like that we report both the
average and best observed across five
runs so why would they use five runs so
if this was a superduper algorithm and
which none of them are this isn't a
slight on their algorithm this isn't
meant to be it's not here anything what
it tells us is that they had to use five
runs because there is some element of
chance involved so you know in one
problem with deep learning is the
problem of replicability right it's hard
to replicate other people's results if
particularly if you use system clocks as
seeds for random number generators right
using the system clock to seed the
random number generator guarantees that
if you run the simulation at even a
millisecond later right that you're
gonna get different results because
gonna be starting with different sets of
parameters now you will get
qualitatively similar results right
you'll be able to repeat the the general
idea of the experiments but you won't
get the exact same results it's kind of
what it's an objection to the whole deep
learning phenomenon and it makes it kind
of not scientific but whatever it works
has an enormous success so we won't
quibble about semantics or you know
philosophical problems but we just need
to know for our purposes that even these
people that invented the algorithm had
to run it several times to get some idea
of what was going to happen because the
algorithm is inherently probabilistic
and so they report averages and
best-case scenarios so that's another
little tidbit and they included results
for both the low dimensional cases where
you receive just a state vector from the
environment as well as the pixel inputs
we won't be doing the pixel inputs for
this particular video but maybe we'll
get to them later I'm trying to work on
that as well
so these are the results and the
interesting tidbit here is that it's
probabilistic it's gonna take five runs
so okay fine other than that we don't
really care about results for now we'll
take a look later but that's not really
our concern at the moment so now we have
a series of questions we have answers to
all those questions we know how we're
gonna handle the Explorer exploit
dilemma we know the purpose of the
target networks we know how we're gonna
handle the noise we know how we're gonna
handle the replay buffer and we know
what the policy actually is going to be
is it's the actual problem it's the
actual actions the agent is going to
take so we know a whole bunch of stuff
so it's time to look at the algorithm
and see how we fill in all the details
so randomly initialize a critic Network
an actor Network with weights theta
Super Q theta super mu so this is
handled by whatever library you use you
don't have to manually initialize
weights but we do know from the
Supplemental materials that they do
constrain these updates to be within
sorry these initializations to be within
some range so
put a note in the back your mind that
you're gonna have to constrain these a
little bit and then it says initialize
target network Q Prime and they mute
Prime with weights that are equal to the
original network so data super EQ Prime
gets initialized to a theta super Q and
theta mu prime gets initialized of theta
super mutant so we will be updating the
weights right off the bat for the target
networks with the evaluation networks
and initialize a replay buffer R now
this is an interesting question how do
you initialize that replay buffer so
I've used a couple different methods you
can just initialize it with all zeros
and then if you do that when you perform
the learning you want to make sure that
you have a number of memories that are
greater than or equal to the mini batch
size of your training so that way you're
not sampling the same states more than
once right if you have 64 memories in a
batch that you want to sample but you
only have 10 memories in your replay
buffer then you're gonna sample let's
say 16 memories and you're gonna sample
each of those memories four times right
so then that's no good so the question
becomes if you update if you neutralize
your replay buffer with zeros then you
have to make sure that you don't learn
until you exit the warm-up period where
the warm-up period is just a number of
steps equal to your replay buffer your
buffer sample size or you can initialize
it with the actual environmental play
now this takes quite a long time you
know the replay buffers are border a
million so if you load the out the
algorithm take a million steps at random
then it's gonna take a long time I
always use zeros and then you know just
wait until the agent fills up the mini
batch size of memories just a minor
detail there then it says for some
number of episodes do so a for loop
initialize a random process in for
action explorations so this is something
now reading it I actually made a little
bit of a mistake so in my previous
implementation I didn't reset the noise
process at the top of every episode
so that's explicit here I must have
missed that line and I've looked at
other people's code some do some don't
but it worked within how many episodes
was it within a 1000 episodes the agent
managed to beat the continuous winter
liner environment so is that critical
maybe not and I think I mentioned that
in the video receiver additional state
observation s1 so for each step of the
episode T equals one to capital T do
select the action a sub T equals mu the
policy plus n sub T according to the
current policy and exploration noise
okay so that's straightforward just use
just feed the state forward what does
that mean it means feed the state
forward through the network receive the
vector output of the action and add some
noise to it
okay execute that action and resuit and
observe reward and new state simple
store the transition you know the old
state action reward a new state in your
replay buffer are okay that's
straightforward each time steps sample a
random mini batch of n transitions from
the replay buffer and then you want to
use that set of transitions to set y sub
I equals so I is sorry having
difficulties here so I is each step of
that is each element of that mini batch
of transitions so you want to basically
loop over that set or do a vectorized
implementation looping is more
straightforward that's what I do I
always opt for the most straightforward
and not necessarily most efficient way
of doing things the first time through
because you want to get it working first
and worry about implementation sorry
efficiency later so set y sub I equals R
sub I plus gamma or gamma is your
discount factor times Q prime of the new
state S sub I plus one times where the
action is chosen according to mu prime
given some weights theta super mutant
and theta super Q prime so what's
important here is
that and this isn't immediately clear if
you're reading this for the first time
what's this is a very important detail
so it's the action must be chosen
according to the target actor Network so
you actually have Q as a function of the
state as well as the output excuse me of
another network that's very important
update the critic by minimizing the loss
basically a weighted average of that y
sub I minus the output from the actual Q
Network where the a sub i's are from the
actually the actions you actually took
during the course of the episode so this
a sub I is from the replay buffer and
these actions right are chosen according
to the target actor network so for each
learning step you're going to have to do
a feed-forward pass of not just this
target Q network but also the target
actor network as well as the evaluation
critic network I hope I said that right
so the feed forward pass of the target
critic network as well as the target
actor Network and the evaluation critic
network as well and then it says update
the actor policy using the sample policy
gradient this is the hardest step in the
whole thing this is the most confusing
part so this is the gradient is equal to
1 over N times the sum so a mean
basically whenever you see 1 over N
times the sum that's a mean the gradient
with respect to actions of Q where the
actions are chosen according to the
policy mu of the current states s times
a gradient with respect to the weights
of MU where they you just put the set of
states ok so that'll be a little bit
tricky to implement so and this is part
of the reason I chose tensor flow for
this particular video is because tensor
flow allows us to calculate gradients
explicitly in pi torts you may have
noticed that all I did was set Q to be a
function of the
the current state as well as the actor
Network and so I loud PI torch to handle
the chain rule this is effectively a
chain rule so let's let's scroll up a
little bit to look at that because this
kind of gave me pause the first 10 times
I read it so this is the hardest part to
implement if you scroll up you see that
this exact same expression appears here
right and this is in reference to this
so it's a gradient with respect to the
weights theta super mu of Q of SN a such
that you're choosing an action a
according to the policy mu so really
what this is is the chain rule so it's
the this grading is a proportional to a
gradient of this quantity times the
gradient of the other quantity it's just
a chain rule from calculus so in the in
the PI torts paper we implemented this
version and we're these are these are
equivalent it's perfectly valid to do
one or the other so in PI tortes we did
this version today we're gonna do this
particular version so that's good to
know
all right so next step on each time step
you want to update the target networks
according to this soft update rule so
theta super EQ prime gets updated as
talen times theta super Q plus 1 minus
tau theta is supercute prime and
likewise for theta super mu prime and
then you just end the two loops so in
practice this looks very very simple but
what do we know off the bat we need a
class for our replay network we need a
class for our knows process we need to
class for the actor in a class for the
critic now you could think that perhaps
have the same but when you look at the
details which we're gonna get to in a
minute you realize you need two separate
classes so you need at least one class
to handle the deep neural networks so
you have at least three classes and I
always add in an agent class on top it's
kind of an interface between the
environment and the deep neural networks
so that's four and we're gonna go with
five but that's for right off the bat
so now that we know the algorithm let's
take a look at the Supplemental details
supplemental information to see
precisely the architectures and
parameters used so we scroll down so
here are the experimental details these
atom for learning the neural network
parameters for the learning rate of ten
to the minus four and ten to the minus
three for the actor and critic
respectively so they tell us alerting
rates 10 to minus 4 10 to the minus 3
for Hydra critic for cue the critic we
included l2 weight decay of 10 to the
minus 2 and use a discount factor of
gamma 0.99 so that gamma is pretty
typical but this important thing is that
for Q and only Q naught mu we included
l2 weight DK of 10 to the minus 2 use a
discount factor of gamma of 0.99 that's
an important detail for the soft target
updates we use tau equals 0.001 so one
part in a thousand that is indeed very
very small okay fine the neural networks
used the rectified non-linearity for all
hidden layers okay the final output
layer the actor was a tangent hyperbolic
layer two bound the actions now tan
hyperbolic goes from minus 1 to plus 1
so in environments in which you have
bounds of plus or minus 2 let's say
you're gonna need a multiplicative
factor so that's just something to keep
in mind the low dimensional networks
but that doesn't that doesn't impact the
tangent hyperbolic he just means there's
a multiplicative factor and they're
related to your environment below
dimensional networks had two hidden
layers with 400 and 300 units
respectively about a hundred thirty
thousand parameters actions were not
included until the second hidden layer
of Q so when you're calculating the
critic function Q you aren't actually
passing forward the action from the very
beginning you're including it as a
separate input at the second hidden
layer of Q that's very important that's
a very important implementation detail
and this is when learning from pixels we
use three convolution layers which we
don't need to know right now we're not
using pixels yet and followed by two
fully connected layers
the final layer weights and biases both
the actor and critic were initialized
from a uniform distribution of plus or
minus 3 by 10 to the minus 3 for the low
dimensional case this was this was to
ensure that the initial outputs for the
policy and value estimates were near
zero the other layers were initialized
from uniform distribution of plus or
minus 1 over square root of F where F as
a fan end of the layer fan is just the
number of input units and the other
layer oh how are that the the the
actions were not included into the fully
connected layers that's for the
convolutional case so here right now I'm
experiencing some confusion reading this
so it says the other ways reinitialize
from uniform distributions related to
the fan in the actions were not included
into the fully connected layers so I'm
guessing since we're talking about fully
connected layers they're talking about
the pixel case right because otherwise
they're all fully connected you know
wouldn't make sense to say specify fully
connected layers so this gives me a
little bit of confusion is this
statement referring to the way I
initially interpreted it it is referring
to both cases for the state vector and
pixel case but whatever I'm gonna
interpret it that way because it seemed
to work
but there's ambiguity there and this is
kind of an example of how reading papers
can be a little bit confusing at times
because the wording isn't always clear
maybe I'm just tired maybe I've been
rambling for about 50 minutes and my
brains turning to mush that's quite
probable actually but anyway we trained
with mini match sizes of 64 for the low
dimensional problems in 69 pixels with a
replay buffer of 10 to the 6 or the
exploration noise process we used
temporally correlated noise in order to
explore well in physical environments to
add momentum once seen it will in Bac
process with theta equals 0.15 and Sigma
equals 0.2 and it tells you what it does
all well and good ok so these are the
implementation details we need 400 units
and 300 minutes for hidden layers atom
optimizer at 10 to the minus 4 for the
actor at 10 to the minus 3 for the
critic for the critic we need an l2
weight decay of 10 the mine
to discount factor of gamma 0.99 and for
the salt that they factor we need point
zero zero one and we need updates we
need initializations that are
proportional to that one over the square
root of fanon for the lower layers and
plus minus point zero zero three zero
zero zero zero three for the final
output layers of our fully cam networks
okay so that's a lot of details we have
everything we need to start implementing
the paper and that only took us about 50
minutes we just might short a thin when
I read it took me quite a while so let's
head back up to the algorithm here and
we'll keep that up as reference for the
remainder of the video because that's
quite critical so let's go ahead and
head back to our code editor and start
coding this up we'll start with the easy
stuff first so let's start coding and we
will start with the probably one of the
most confusing aspects of the problem of
the Ornstein uhlenbeck action noise now
you can go ahead and do a google search
for it and you'll find a Wikipedia
article that talks a lot about the
physical processes behind a lot of
mathematical derivations and that's not
particularly helpful so if you want to
be a physicist I invite you to read that
and check it out it's got some pretty
cool stuff it took me back to my grad
school days but we have a different
mission in mind for the moment the
mission now is to find a code
implementation of this that we can use
in our problem so if you then do a
Google search for Ornstein uhlenbeck
github as and you want to find someone's
github example for it you end up with a
nice example from the open AI baseline
library that shows you the precise form
of it so let me show you that one second
so you can see it here in the github
there is a whole class for this right
here that I've highlighted and this
looks to do precisely what we want it
has previous plus a delta term and a DT
term so it looks like it's going to
create correlations through this X
previous term there's a reset function
to reset the noise which we may want to
use and there's this representation
which we'll probably skip because we
know what we're doing and it's not
really critical for this particular
it would be nice if you were writing a
library as these guys were so they
included the representation method so
let's go ahead and code that up in the
editor and that will tackle our first
class so I'm gonna leave the notes up
there for now they do no harm they're
just comments at the top of the file so
the first thing we'll need is to import
numpy as NP we know we can go ahead and
start and say import tensor flow as TF
we're going to need tensor flow we may
need something like OS to handle model
savings so we can go ahead and import
that as well just a fun fact it is
considered good practice to import your
system level packages first and followed
by your library packages second in
numerical order followed by your own
personal code in numerical order so
that's the imports that we need to start
let's go ahead and code up our class
we'll call it o you action noise and
that'll just be derived from the base
object so the initializer will take a mu
a Sigma now they said they used a
default value of I believe 0.15 and a
theta of 0.2 a DT term is something like
1 by 10 to the minus 2 and our X naught
will save as none and again if you have
any doubts on that just go check out the
open AI baselines for it their
implementation is probably correct right
I'll give them the benefit of the doubt
so go ahead and save your parameters as
usual
so we have a mu a theta a DT Sigma and X
0 and we'll go ahead and call the reset
function at the top now they override
the call method and what this does is it
enables you to say noise equals oh you
an action noise and then when you want
to get the noise you just say our noise
equals noise you can use the parenthesis
that's what overall writing call does
that's a good little tidbit to know so
we want do you implement the equation
that they gave us it's L self that X
previous plus self dot theta times mu
minus X previous times self DT plus
Sigma times at numpy square root self
dot DT times numpy random normal for the
size of mu and set the X previous to the
current value that's how you create the
temporal correlations and return the
value of the noise so we don't have a
value for x previous so we have to set
that with the reset function which takes
no parameters self that X previous
equals x naught if self dot x naught is
not none else numpy zeros like self dot
mia and that's it for the noise function
that's pretty straightforward so that's
all well and good so we have one one
function down so we've taken care of the
noise sorry have one class now we've
taken care of the noise and now we can
move on to the replay buffer so this
will be something similar to what I've
been lamented in the past there are many
different implementations and ways of
implementing this many people we use a
built-in Python data structure called a
DQ or a deck I think it's DQ is the
pronunciation basically it's a queue
that you fill up over time and that's
perfectly valid you can do that there's
no reason not to I prefer using a set of
arrays and using numpy to facilitate
that the reason being that we can
tightly control the data types of the
stuff that we're saving for this
pendulum environment it doesn't really
matter but as you get more involved in
this field you will see that you are
saving stuff that has varying sizes so
if you're trying to save images let's
say from the one of the Atari libraries
or a mu Joko environment or something
like that hope I pronounced that
correctly you'll see that this memory
can explode quite quickly you can eat
into your RAM so the ability to
manipulate the underlying data type
representation whether you want to use
single or double precision for either
your floating-point numbers or integers
is critical to memory management as well
as taking advantage of some other
optimizations for NVIDIA GPUs in the
touring class and above so I always use
the numpy arrays because it's a clean
implementation that allows manipulation
of data types you can use the DQ if you
want it's perfectly valid so our
separate class has its own initializer
of course so we're going to want to pass
in a maximum size the input shape and
the number of actions right because we
have to store the state action reward
and new state tuples we're also going to
want to facilitate the use of the done
flag so we'll have an extra parameter in
here and the reason behind that is
intimately related to how the how the
bellman equation is calculated it took
me a second to think of that at the end
of the episode the agent receives no
further rewards and so the expected
feature reward the discounted future
reward if you will is identically zero
so you have to multiply the reward for
the next state by zero if that next
state follows the terminal state if your
current state is terminal in the next
state is following the terminal state so
you don't want to take into account
anything from that he expected future
rewards because they're identically zero
so we need a done flag this is all I
wanted to say
so we save our parameters I only need to
say that we can say self mmm counter
equals zero and that will keep track of
the position of our most recently saved
memory state memory and arrived up by
zeros mm size by input shape new state
memory same same deal you know it's just
just totally the same good grief
okay so now we have the say action
memory and that's known pi 0 cell top
men's eyes by sulfa n actions we didn't
save an action this did B so we'll just
call it 10 actions we have the reward
memory and that's just a scalar value so
that only gets shaped self mem size we
also need the terminal memory from the
memory and that'll be shaped self dot
men size and I have it numpy float32 if
I recall correctly that is due to the
data types in the PI torch
implementation is probably not necessary
here in the tensorflow implementation
but I left it the same way just to be
consistent it doesn't hurt anything so
next we need a function to store a
current transition so that'll take a
state action reward new state and a done
flag as input so the index of where we
want to store that memory is the memory
counter modulus the men size so for any
men can or less than mem sighs this just
returns mem counter for anything larger
than mem size it just wraps around so if
you have a million memories all the way
up from zero to nine hundred nine
thousand nine hundred ninety nine it
will be that number and then once it's a
million it wraps back round to 0 and
then 1 and 2 and so on and so forth and
so that way your overwriting memories at
the earliest part of the array with the
newest memories
precisely as they described in the paper
if you're using the DQ map method then I
believe you would just pop it off of the
left I believe now don't quote me
because I haven't really used that
implementation but from what I've read
that's how it operates new state memory
sub index equals state underscore reward
memory equals sub index reward as action
memory now keep in mind that the actions
in this case are arrays themselves so
it's an array of arrays just keep that
in the back your mind so that you can
visualize the problem we're trying to
solve here next up we have the terminal
memory now a little twist here is that
we want this to be 1 minus int of done
so done is either true or false so you
don't want to count the rewards after
the episode has ended so when done is
true you want to multiply by 0 so 1
minus in to true is 1 minus 1 which is 0
and when it's not over it's 1 minus 0
which is just 1 so that's precisely the
behavior we want and finally you want to
increment men counter by 1 every time
you store em new memory next we need a
function to sample our buffer and we
want to pass in a batch size
alternatively you could make batch size
a member variable of this class it's not
really a big deal I just did it this way
for whatever reason my chose to do it
that way so what we want to do is we
want to find the minimum either so let's
back up for a second so what we want is
to sample the memories from either the
0th position all the way up to the most
filled memory the last filled memory so
if you have less than the max memory you
want to go from 0 to mem counter
otherwise you want to sample anywhere in
that whole interval so maximum equals
the minimum of over of either mem
counter or
sighs and the reason you don't want to
just use mem can or is that mem counter
goes larger than mem size so if you try
to tell it to select something from the
range men counter when them counter is
greater than mem size you'll end up
trying to access elements of the array
that aren't there and it'll throw an
error so that's why you need this step
next you want to take a random choice of
from zero to maximum of a size batch
size so then you just want to gather
those states from the respective arrays
like so I forgot the self of course new
states actions
rewards and call it terminal
batch I believe that's everything
and you wanna return the state's actions
rewards new states and terminal okay so
so now we are done with the replay
buffer class so that's actually pretty
straightforward and if you've seen some
of my other videos on deep key learning
then you've seen pretty much the same of
implementation
I just typically kept it in the aging
class then we're kind of refining my
approach getting more sophisticated over
time so make sense this ticket in its
own class so we're already like 40
percent of the way there we've got five
classes in total so that's good news so
next up we have to contend with the
actor and critic networks so we'll go
ahead and start with the actor and from
there keep in mind that we have two
actor networks and we're gonna have to
contend with some of the peculiarities
and weaith tensorflow likes to do stuff
so let's get started the actor and of
course in tensorflow you don't derive
from any particular class we're on PI
torch you would derive from an end up
module don't know what I'm doing there
definite so we'll need a learning rate
number of actions unnamed and the name
is there to distinguish the regular
actor network from the target actor
network input dims we're gonna want to
pass it a session so tensorflow has the
construct of the session which houses
the graph and all the variables and
parameters and stuff like that you can
have each class having its own session
but it's more tidy to pass in a single
session to each of the classes a number
of dimensions for the first fully
connected layers so of course I should
be 400 if we're going to implement the
paper precisely fc2 DIMMs is 300 an
action bound a batch size that defaults
to 64 a checkpoint directory and the
purpose of that is to save our model
hand in the case of the pendulum it
doesn't really matter because it's so
quick to run but in general you want a
way of saving these models because it
can take a long time to run so we'll
save our learning rate number of actions
and all of the parameters we passed in
dot fc-1 dims and the purpose of this
action bound is to accommodate
environments where the action is either
greater than plus or minus negative one
so if you can go from plus or minus to
the tangent hyperbolic is only gonna
sample like half your range right from
plus minus one and so you won't have an
action bound and there is a
multiplicative factor to make sure that
you can sample the full range of the
actions available to your agent and we
need to say that checkpoint Dirar
and finally we want to call a build
network function that's not final but
we'll call the build Network function
next up since we have to do the soft
cloning the soft update rule for the
target actor class and target critic
then we know that we have to find a way
of keeping track of the parameters in
each Network so we're gonna keep track
of them here in the variable params and
it's tensorflow dot trainable variables
with a scope of a self dot name so the
we have a single session in a single
graph and you're gonna have multiple
deep neural networks within that graph
we want we don't want to update the
critic network when we're trying to do
the after Network and vice versa right
we want those to be independent and so
we scoped them with their own name so
that tensorflow knows hey this is a
totally different set of parameters from
this
that will aid in copying stuff later and
also make sure that everything is nice
and tidy and the scope is what
facilitates that will also need a saver
object to save the model let's make a
checkpoint file and that's where we use
OS and that will clone into check
pointer and the name plus underscore DD
PG checkpoint so this will automatically
scope the save files for us so that way
we don't confuse the parameters for the
target actor and actor or critic and
target critic or even actor and critic
for that matter very important so we
were gonna have to calculate some
gradients and we're gonna do that by
hand so we're gonna need a series of
functions that will facilitate that and
the first of which is the unnormalized
actor gradients and that is given my
tensorflow radians cell top mu cell top
params and minus self dot action in
gradient so we're gonna calculate some
you will be the MU from the paper the
actual actions of the agent params are
our network parameters and this action
gradients so let's go back to the paper
for a second so we can get some idea
what i'm talking about here so if we
look at the algorithm we can see that
we're going to need these gradients of
the critic function with respect to the
actions taken we're also going to need
the gradient of the actual mu with
respect to the weights of the network so
we're passing in into tensor flow
gradients this function mu the
parameters to get the gradient with
respect to those parameters and then
we're gonna have to calculate the
gradient of the critic with respect to
the actions taken so we'll have to
calculate this later that's a
placeholder that's the minus self-taught
action gradient and we're gonna
calculate that in the learning function
but that's where all of that comes from
so now let's go back to the code editor
and continue
so that's our uh normalized actor
gradients and uh normalized just because
we're going to take one over the sum 1
over N times a sum we need a function
for performing that normalization so the
actor gradients has to be this parameter
has to be a list so we cast it as a list
I'm just going to map a lambda function
and XT F dot div X and batch size no big
deal there so optimize is our
optimization step and of course that's
the atom optimizer we want to optimize
with the learning rate of self doubt
learning rate and we want to apply
gradients so typically we use dot
minimize loss but in this case we're
calculating our gradients manually so we
need to apply those gradients and what
do we want to apply want to apply the
actor gradients to the programs and I
would encourage you to go look at the
tensor flow code for all of these the
videos getting a little bit long we're
already up to like an hour and 20 hour
and 10 20 minutes something like that so
I'm not gonna go through all the
documentation for tensor flow feel free
to look that up I had to when I was
building this house so next up we need
to build our network
so this is how we're gonna handle the
scoping TF dot variable underscore scope
self that names that way every network
gets its own scope we need a placeholder
for the input that'd be a 32 bit
floating number shape of nun which is
batch size you can put dims
beiongs and that won't work let's put
this on its own line and we're gonna
give it a name it's not critical
the name parameter is just for debugging
if something goes wrong then you can
kind of trace where it went wrong makes
life a little bit easier the action
gradient is also a placeholder that is
what we're gonna calculate in the learn
function for the agent and that gets a
shape of nun by and actions so it'll be
the gradient of cute respect to each
action so it has number of dimensions
but there's actions and so those are our
two placeholder variables now we get to
construct the actual network so let's
handle the initialization first so f1 is
the fan-in it's 1 divided by numpy
square root FC 1 dims and our dense 1 TF
layers dot dense and that takes self but
input as input with self dot FC 1 dims
as units our kernel initializer egos
random I forgot an importance it's
random uniform one second minus F 1 2 F
1 and the bias initializer current L no
that's not right Kernell bias
initializer random
uniform minus F 1 to F 1 that gets to
parentheses so we have to come back up
to our imports import tensor flow dot
initializers know so we have to come
back up here and say from tensor flow
without initializers in this shell
either import random uniform and now
we're good to go let's come back down
here we have dense one now we want to do
the batch normalization so batch 1
equals TF layers badge normalization
dense one and that doesn't get
initialized so now let's activate our
first layer and that's just the rail u
activation of the batch normal batch
normed now it is an open debate from
what I've read online about whether or
not you should do the activation before
or after the batch normalization I'm in
the camp of doing it after the
activation after the batch norm that's
because the real activation function at
least in at least in the case of rail
you so NREL you you lop off everything
lower than zero so your statistics might
get skewed to be positive instead of
maybe they're zero maybe they're
negative who knows so I think the batch
norm is probably best before the
activation and indeed this works out
this is something you can play with so
go ahead and fork this repo and play
around with it and see how much of a
difference it makes for you maybe I
missed something when I try to do it the
other way it's entirely possible I miss
stuff all the time so you know it's
something you can improve upon that's
how I chose to do it and it seems to
work and who knows maybe other
implementations work as well so now
let's add some space so f2 is 1 over
square root
su to Tim's dents to is similar that
takes layer one activation as input with
FC two dims you don't need that I'm
gonna come up here and copy this there
we go except we have to change f1 to f2
perfect then we have batch two and that
takes dents to is input your to
activation batch 2 now finally we have
the output layer which is the actual
policy of our agent the deterministic
policy of course and from the paper that
gets initialized with the value of zero
point zero is zero three and we're going
to call this mu that gets layered to
activation as input and that needs and
actions as the number of output units
what's our activation that is tangent
hyperbolic tanh CH and I will go ahead
and copy the initializers here of course
that gets f3 not f2
perfect can I tap that I can okay so
that is mu and then we want to take into
account the fact that our environment
may very well require actions that have
values plus greater than plus or minus
one so self dot mu is TF that multiplied
with mu and the action bound an action
bound will be you know something like
two it needs to be positive so that way
you don't flip the actions but that's
pretty straightforward so now we've
built our network built our network next
thing we need is a way of getting the
actual actions out of the network so we
have a prediction function that takes
some inputs and you want to return self
dot sass run self dot M you with a feed
dictionary of self dot input and pass in
inputs that's all that is there is to
passing the doing the feed-forward kind
of an interesting contrast to how pi
torch does it with the explicit
construction of the feed-forward
function this just runs the session on
this and then goes back and finds all
the associations between the respective
variables nice and simple
now we need a function to Train and
that'll take inputs and gradients this
is what will perform the actual back
propagation through the network and you
want to run self dot optimized that's
our function that accommodates learning
with a feed and dictionary of inputs
inputs and self dot action gradient
gradients so that is also reasonably
straightforward so you know let's format
that a little bit better alright so that
is our training function next we need
two functions to accommodate the loading
and the saving of the model so define
save checkpoint and print then you want
to say self dot saver dot save very
creative donuts save the current session
to the checkpoint file and the load
checkpoint function is the same thing
just in Reverse so here we want to print
floating checkpoint self dot saver dot
restore that session and the Check Point
file so that will you can only call this
after and Stan she ating the agent so it
will have a default session with some
initialized values and you want to load
the variables from the checkpoint file
into that checkpoint and that is it for
the actor class this is reasonably
straightforward the only real mojo here
is the actor gradients and this is just
two functions that accommodate the fact
that we are going to manually calculate
the gradient of the critic with respect
to the actions taken so let's go ahead
and do the critic class next that is
also very similar so that again derives
from the base object gets an initializer
and it's pretty much the same number of
actions a name input dims a session s
you won bin's se2 dims a batch size will
default to 64 and a check pointer will
default to this just a note you have to
do a make derp on this temps livecd DPG
first otherwise it'll bark at you not a
big deal just something to be aware of
since it's identical let's go ahead and
copy a good chunk of this stuff here
what exactly is the same all of this now
we need the checkpoint file let's grab
that ctrl C come down here control V and
voila it is all the same so
very straightforward nothing too magical
about that so now let's handle the
optimizer means we already have a we've
already called the function to build our
network we can define our optimizer so
the self thought optimize TF train Adam
optimizer and we're gonna minimize the
loss which we will calculate in the
build Network function and we also need
a function to actually calculate the
gradients of Q with respect hey so we
have self - ingredients self dot Q and
actions let's build our network with
Tina sorry TF a variable scope self that
name so now we need our placeholders
again we need subletting placeholder
float32 we need a shape nun by input
dims now if you're not too familiar with
tensorflow
specifying none in the first dimension
tell sensor flow you're gonna have some
type of batch of inputs and you don't
know what that batch size will be
beforehand so just expect anything and
let's delete that say i need a comma for
sure and say name equals inputs here we
go
did i forget a comma up here let's just
make sure i did not okay so we also need
the actions because remember we only
take into account the actions and the
second hidden layer of the critic neural
network
I have float 342 shape none by and
actions name of actions now much like
with q-learning we have a target value
let me just go back to the paper really
quickly show you what that precisely
will be so that target value will be
this quantity here and we will calculate
that in the learning function as we as
we get to the agent class so let's go
back to the code editor and finish this
up so Q target is just another
placeholder and that's a floating point
number done by one it's a scalar so it
is shaped batch size by one and we will
call it targets okay so now we have a
pretty similar setup to the actor
Network so let's go ahead and come up
here and copy this no not all that just
this and come back down here so f1 we
recognize that's just the fan-in we have
a dense layer for the inputs and we want
to initialize that with a random number
pretty straightforward then we can come
up to f2 and copy that as as well sorry
the second layers it'll be a little bit
different but we'll handle that
momentarily so now f2 the layer 2 is
pretty similar the only real difference
is that we want to get rid of that
activation and the reason we want to get
rid of that activation is because after
I do the batch norm we have to take into
account the actions so we need another
layer so action in
Steve layers dense it's going to take in
cellphone actions which will pass in
from the learning function and that's
going to output F c2 dims
with a value activation so then our
state actions will be the the addition
of the batch two and the action in and
then we want to go ahead and activate
that okay so this is something else I
pointed out in my PI torch video where
this is a point of debate with the way
I've implemented this I've done it a
couple different ways they've done the
different variations and this is what I
found to work I'm doing a double
activation here so I'm activating the
rel you I'm doing the Arroyo activation
on the actions in on the output of that
that dense layer and then I'm activating
the sum now the the Raju function is non
commutative with respect to the addition
functions so the value of the sum is
different than the sum of the values and
you can prove that to yourself on a
sheet of paper but it's debatable on
whether or not the way I've done it is
correct it seems to work so I'm gonna
stick with it for now again for kit
cloning change it up see how it works
and improve it for me that would be
fantastic
then make a pull request and I'll
disseminate that to the community so we
have our state actions now we need to
calculate the actual output of the layer
and an f3 is our uniform initializer for
our final layer which is self dot Q
those all areas that dense that takes
state actions as input outputs a single
unit and we have the kernel initializers
and bias initializers similar to up here
let's paste that OOP there we go that's
a little bit better still got a whole
bunch of white space there all right so
we are missing one thing and that one
thing is the regularizer so as they said
on the paper they have L to regular
regularization on the critic so we do
that with kernel regular Iser equals TF
Kerris regul our eyes errs dot l2 or the
value zero zero one that 0 1 sorry so
that is that for the cue and notice that
it outputs one unit and it outputs a
single unit because this is a scalar
value you want the value of the
particular state action pair finally we
have the loss function and that's just a
mean squared error error cue target and
Q so Q target is the placeholder up here
and that's what we'll pass in from the
learn function from the agent and self
dot q is the output of the deep neural
network okay so now similar to our
critic we have a prediction function it
takes inputs and actions and you want to
return self that's a stun self dot Q
with a feed dictionary of sub that input
inputs and actions oops
next you need a training function and
that's slightly more complicated than
the actor visa takes in the inputs
actions and a target and you want to
return self assess run so to optimize
with a feed dictionary of sub that input
inputs self dot actions actions and Q
target space gun that's a little wonky
whatever we'll leave it that's a
training function next we need a
function to get the action gradients and
that'll run that action gradients
operation up above so let's get that
again takes inputs and actions as input
and you want to return self that session
run self dot action ingredients with a
its own feed dictionary equals self dot
input inputs and self out actions
actions
and then we also have the save and load
checkpoint functions which are identical
to the actor siliceous copy and paste
those there we go
so that is it for the critic class so
now we have most of what we need we have
our our our noise our replay buffer our
actor and our critic now all we need is
our agent now the agent is what ties
everything together it handles the
learning functionality it allows the
noise the memory of the replay buffer as
well as the four different deep neural
networks and that derives from the face
object
initializer is a little bit long and
that takes an alpha and a beta these are
the learning rates for the actor and
critic respectively recall from what we
read in the paper they use 0 0 0 1 and 0
0 1 for both networks we need input dims
tau the environment that's how we're
going to get the action bounds a gamma
is 0.99 for the paper in this case we
need number of actions equals to a MEMS
eyes for our memory of 1 million player
1 size of 400 and layer 2 size of 300
and a batch size of 64 so of course we
want to save all of our parameters
we'll need the memory and that's just a
replay buffer max sighs whoops input
dims and number of actions we will need
a batch sighs here's where we're gonna
store the session and this is so that we
have a single session for all four
networks and I believe and I believe
don't quote me on this but I tried it
with an individual Network for sorry an
individual session for each network and
it was very unhappy when I was
attempting to copy over parameters from
one network to another I figured there
was some scoping issues so I just
simplified it by having a single session
there's no real reason that I can think
up to have more than one and that is an
actor that gets alpha a number of
actions the name is just actor input
dims the session layer one sized layer
to size action space dot high and that's
our action bounce the actions based out
high next we have a critic that gets
beta and actions its name is just critic
the dims self that session there one
sized layer to size and we don't pass in
anything about the environment there so
now we can just copy these and instead
of actor it is target actor
and let's go ahead and clean up and be
consistent with our pet bait style
guides always important and that
actually makes you stand out I've worked
on projects where the manager was quite
happy to see that I had a somewhat
strict adherence to it just something to
take note of so then we have a target
critic as well and we will clean up this
and so that is all four of our deep
neural networks that's pretty
straightforward so now we need noise
that's a no you action noise with mu
equals numpy zeroes in the shape and
actions so now we need operations to
perform the soft updates so the first
time I tried it I defined it as its own
separate function and that was a
disaster it was a disaster because it
would get progressively slower at each
soft update and I don't quite know the
reason for that I just know that that's
what happened and so when I moved it
into the initializer and defined one
operation
I'm guessing it's because it adds every
time you call it it probably adds
something to the graph so that adds
overhead to the calculation that's my
guess I don't know that's accurate it's
just kind of how I reasoned it but
anyway let's go ahead and define our
update operations here so what we want
to do is iterate over our target critic
parameters and call the assignment
operation what we want to assign we want
to assign the product of critic params
and self that towel plus give that
multiply self dot target critic params
up I times or and no that should be a
sorry a comma comma and one - cell towel
so we get to let's hit man that's and
that is a list comprehension for I in
range length of target critic top params
I gets that you don't need that I
believe no so then we have a similar
operation for the actor we just want to
swap actor and critic target actor so
thought actor actor dot params DUP
params I do the same thing here didn't I
target actor
and up here da prams okay target actor
actor and then target actor there so now
we have our update soft update
operations according to the paper
finally we have constructed all the
graphs you know for the whole four
networks so we have to initialize our
variables self that section that run TF
global variables initializer you can't
really run anything without initializing
it and as per the paper at the very
beginning we want to update the network
parameters and at the beginning we want
to pass in the we want the target
networks to get updated with the full
ver the full value of the critic of the
evaluation networks and so I'm passing
in a parameter of first equals true so
since it's confusing let's do that first
that function first update network
parameters first will default to false
so if first we need to say old tau
equals self dot tau I need to save the
old value of tau to set it again so that
I can reset it so that's how it goes one
and say self dot target critic session
run update critic cell targets actor
that session that run self dot update
actor and as I recall this is important
which session used to run the update
although maybe not since I'm using only
one session if you want to play around
with it go ahead
and then go ahead and reset the towel to
the old value because you only want to
do this particular update where you
update the target network with the
original network full values on the
first turn on the first go through
otherwise just go ahead and run the
update function boom so next we need a
way of storing transitions self state
action reward new state and done so self
up memory dot store transition you want
to store all this stuff this is just an
interface from one class to another you
know this may or may not be great
computer science practice but it works
next we want a way of choosing an action
and that should take a state as input
since we have defined the input variable
to be shaped batch size by n actions you
want to reshape the state to be 1 by
sorry it should be 1 by the observation
space new access all and that's because
we have the come up here for the actor
Network just so we're clear it is
because this has shape none by input
dims so if you just pass in the
observation vector that has shape input
dims and it's going to get it's gonna
get uppity with you
so you just have to reshape it because
you're only passing in a single
observation to determine what action to
take so mu actor dot predict state noise
equals self dot noise new prime
you guys mu plus noise return Sub Zero
so this returns a tuple so you want the
0th element so now we have the learning
function and of course this is where all
the magic happens so if you have not
filled up the memory then you want to go
ahead and bail out otherwise you want to
go ahead and sample your memory sometime
memory that sample buffer batch size so
next we need to do the update from the
paper so let's go back to the paper and
make sure we are clear on that so we
need to we already sampled this so we
need to calculate this and to do that
we're gonna need the q prime the target
critic network as output as well as the
output from the target actor Network and
then we use that to update the loss for
the critic and then we're gonna need the
output from the critic as well as from
the actor network so we need to
basically pass States and actions
through all four networks to get the
training function the learning function
so let's go ahead and head back to the
code editor and do that so our critic by
you for Q prime so cute critic value
underscore sub left target critic
predict and you want to pass in the new
states and you will also want to pass in
the actions that come from the target
actor
new state I need one extra parentheses
there so then we want to calculate the Y
sub i's for the targets so that's an
empty list for J and range set up batch
size target dot append reward critic
value underscore J times done sub J and
that's where the kept harping on getting
no rewards after the terminal state
that's where that comes from
when done is true then it's 1 minus true
which is 0 so you're multiplying this
quantity by 0 so you don't take into
account the value of the next state
right which is calculated up here you
only take into account the most recent
reward as you would want so then we just
want to reshape that target into
something that is batch size by 1 that's
to be consistent with our placeholders
and now we want to call the critic train
function right because we have
everything we need we have the state's
actions and targets with States and
actions from the replay buffer and the
target from this calculation here very
easy now we need to do the actor update
so the action else self dot actor dot
predict we get the predictions from the
actor for this states are grads the
gradients get action gradients state
payouts that'll get the remember that'll
do a feed forward and get the gradient
of the critic with respect to the
actions taken and then you want to train
the actor state and grads the gradients
it's a tuple so you want to dereference
it and get the 0th element and then
finally you want to update network
parameters whoo okay so that is it for
the learn function now we have two other
bookkeeping functions to handle which is
save models and this will save all of
our models so a self thought actor does
save check point
self thought target actor save check
point
so plot critic and a function to load
models sounds like a dog fine out there
so we want to load check points instead
of saving them
load check points load and load so that
is it for the aging class that only took
about an hour so we're up to about two
hours for the video so longest one yet
so this is an enormous amount of work
this is already three hundred ten lines
of code if you've made it this far
congratulations this is no mean feat
this took me you know a couple weeks to
hammer through but we've gotten through
it in a couple hours so this is all
there is to the implementation now we
have to actually test it so let's open
up a new file and save that as main
tensorflow pi and what we want to do now
is go ahead and test this out in the
pendulum environment
we call it tensorflow original import
our agent
we need Jim we need do we need numpy for
this yes we do
we need we don't need tensor flow from
utils import plot learning and we don't
need OS so we will have a score history
I know what I want to do that with a say
if name equals main now we want to say
env Jim not make Bend you glum - be zero
agent equals agent it gets a learning
rate of zero zero zero one a beta of
zero one put dims 303 towel zero one
pass in our environment batch size 64
being verbose here and it looks like
when I ran this I actually use different
layer sizes well that's an issue for
hyper parameter tuning I just want to
demonstrate that this works and actions
equals one so
when I got good results for this I
actually used 800 by 600 and I cut these
learning rates in half but we'll go
ahead and use the values from the paper
sometimes I do a hyper parameter tuning
other thing we need to do is set our
random seed you know we can just put it
here
whatever the reason we want to do this
is for replicability and i have yet to
see any limitation of this where they
don't set the random seed and i've tried
it without it and you don't get very
good sampling of a replay buffer so this
seems to be a critical step and most
implementations I've seen on github do
the same thing so let's go ahead and
play our episodes say a thousand games
you know view that reset we forgot our
score history of course that's to keep
track of the scores over the course of
our games don't is false and the score
for the episode is zero let's play the
episode say act agent dot shoes action
takes jobs as input new state reward
done info equal C and V dot step act
agent got remember Hobbs Act reward new
state and done I guess the int done
really isn't necessary we take care of
that in the replay buffer funk funk
class but you know doesn't hurt to be
explicit and then you want to rebel we
want to learn on each time step because
this is a temporal difference method
keep track of your score and set your
old state to be the new state so that
way when you choose an action on the
next step you are using the most recent
information finally at the end of every
episode you want to append that score to
the score history and print episode I
score percent up to F score 100 game
average person not to have percent numpy
mean a score history last 100 games -
100 on one more and at the end equals
pendulum dot PNG plot learning plot
learning score history file name and a
window of 100 the reason I choose a
window of 100 is because many
environments to find salt as trailing
100 games over some amount the pendulum
doesn't actually have a solved amount so
what we get is actually on par with some
of the best results people have on the
leaderboard so it looks like it does
pretty well so that is it for the main
function let's go ahead and head to the
terminal and see how many typos I made
all right here we are let's go ahead and
run the main file invalid syntax I have
an extra print to see I'm just going to
delete that really quick run that I have
the star out of place let's go back to
the code editor and handle that so it
looks like it is on line 95 which is
here
all right back to the terminal let's try
it again
and it says line 198 invalid syntax oh
it's because it's a comma instead of a
colon
all right I'll fix that once more all
right so that was close so actor object
has no attribute input dims line 95 no
ok that's easy
let's head back so it's in line 95 just
means I forgot to save input dims and
that probably means I forgot it and then
critic as well since I did it cut and
paste yes it does
alright now we'll go back to the
terminal okay that's the last one
all right moment of truth
critic takes one positional argument but
seven were given good grief okay one
second so that is of course in the agent
function so I have line two thirty four
one two three four five six seven
parameters indeed so critic takes
learning rate number of actions name
input Tim session interesting one two
three four five six seven
what have I done oh that's why it's
class critic of course all right let's
go back to the terminal and see what
happens named action bound is not
defined and that is in the line 148 okay
line 148 that is in the critic ah that's
because I don't need it there let's
delete it that was just for the actor
it's because I cut and pasted always
dangerous I tried to save a few
keystrokes too
my hands and ended up wasting time
instead all right it's go back to the
terminal
all right actor has no attribute inputs
that is on line 126 self dot inputs it's
probably self dot input yes that's why I
do the same thing here okay
perfect and it runs so I'll let that run
for a second but I let it run for a
thousand games earlier and this is the
output I got now keep in mind it's a
slightly different parameters the point
here isn't that whether or not we can
replicate the results because we don't
even know what the results really were
because they express it as a fraction of
a planning a fraction of the performance
of a planning agent so who knows what
that really means I did a little bit of
hybrid parameter tuning all I did was
double the number of input units and
have the learning rate and I ended up
with something that looks like this so
you can see it gets around 150 or so
steps because they're on hundred years
so steps to salt and if you check the
leaderboards that it shows that that's
actually a reasonable number some of the
best environments only have 152 steps
some of them do a little bit better
sorry best agents solvent in hunter 52
steps or achieve a best score run or
vide steps but it's pretty reasonable so
so the default implementation looks like
it's very very slow to learn you can see
how it's kind of starts out band gets
worse and then gets starts to get a
little bit better so that's pretty
typical you see this you know
oscillation and performance over time
pretty frequently but that is that that
is how you go from an implementation in
about two hours of course it took me you
know many you know a couple many times
that to get this set up for you guys but
I hope this is helpful
I'm going to milk this for all it's
worth this has been a tough project so
I'm gonna present many many more
environments in the future I may even do
a video like this for pi torch I have
yet to work on a kerosene
limitation for this but there are many
more
DDP G videos to come so subscribe to
make sure you don't miss that leave a
comment share this if you found it
helpful that helps me immensely I would
really appreciate it and I'll see you
all in the next video welcome back
everybody in this tutorial you are gonna
code a deterministic policy gradient
agent to beat the continuous lunar
lander environment in pi torch no prior
experience needed you don't need to know
anything about deep reinforcement
learning you just have to follow along
let's get started
so we start as usual with our imports
will need OS to handle file operations
and all of this stuff from torch that
we've come to expect as well as numpy
I'm not going to do a full overview of
the paper that will be in a future video
where I will show you how to go from the
paper to an actual implementation of
deep deterministic policy gradients so
make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss that but in this video we're just
going to get at the very high-level
overview the 50,000 foot view if you
will that will be sufficient to get an
agent to beat the continuous lunar
lander environment so that's good enough
so the gist of this is we're gonna need
several different classes so we'll need
a class to encourage exploration in
other words the type of noise and you
might have guessed that from the word
deterministic it means that the policy
is deterministic as in it chooses some
action with certainty and so if it is
purely deterministic you can't really
explore so we'll need a class to handle
that we'll also need a class to handle
the replay memory because deep
deterministic policy gradients works by
combining the magic of actor critic
methods with the magic of deep Q
learning which of course has a replay
buffer and we'll also need classes for
our critic and our actor as well as the
agent so that's kind of a mouthful we'll
handle them one bit at a time and we
will start with the noise so this class
is called oh you action noise and the
öyou stands for Ornstein Willem Beck
so that is a type of noise from physics
that models the motion of a Brownian
particle meaning this particle subject
to a random walk based on interactions
with other nearby particles it gives you
a temporally correlated meaning
correlated in time set type of noise
that centers around a mean of zero so
we're gonna have a number of parameters
mu a Sigma a theta if I could type that
would be fantastic as well as a DT as in
the differential with respect to time
and an initial value that will get an
original value of none so if you want to
know more about it then just go ahead
and check out the Wikipedia article but
the overview I gave you is sufficient
for this tutorial so of course we want
to save all of our values
X zero and we want to call a reset
function so the reset function will
reset the temporal correlation which you
may want to do that from time to time
turns out it's not necessary for our
particular implementation but it is a
good function to have nonetheless so
next we're gonna override the call
function if you aren't familiar with
this this allows you to say noise equals
oh you action noise and then call noise
so that allows you to instead of saying
noise get noise just say noise with
parenthesis or whatever the name of the
object is so that's overriding the call
function so we'll have an equation for
that X previous plus theta times the
quantity mu minus self dot X previous
times self DT plus self dot Sigma times
numpy square root cell DT times MP
random normal size equals mu shape so
it's a type of random normal noise that
is correlated in time through this mu
minus X previous term and every time you
calculate a new value you want to set
the old value the previous value to the
new one and go ahead and return the
value so the reset function all that
does is check to make sure x0 exists if
it doesn't it sets it equal to some 0
value so so X previous equals Delta X
naught if is not none else numpy zeros
like in the shape of self dot mutant
that's it for the action noise again
this will be used in our actor class to
add in some exploration noise to the
action selection next we need the replay
buffer class and this is pretty
straightforward it's just going to be
set of numpy arrays in the shape of the
action space number the observation
space and rewards so that way we can
have a memory of events that have
happened
so we can sample them during the
learning step if you haven't seen my
videos on deep q-learning
please check those out they will make
all this much more clear as well as
checking out the videos on actor critic
methods because this again D DPG kind of
combines actor critic with deep key
learnings so that will really be helpful
for you I'll go ahead and link those
here as well so that way you can get
educated so scroll down a bit we want to
save our men's eyes as max size so then
then counter we'll start out at zero
again this is just gonna be a set of
arrays that keep track or matrices in
this case that keep track of the state
reward action transitions and that will
be in shape immense eyes so however
number of memories we want to store and
input shape so if you are relatively new
to Python this star variable idiom it
isn't a pointer if you're coming from C
or C++ it is an idiom that means to
unpack a tuple so this makes our class
extensible so we can pass in a list of a
single element as in the case of the
lunar lander and continuous winter and
land environment that we'll use today or
later on when we get to the continuous
car racing environment we'll have images
from the screen so this will accommodate
both types of observation vectors it's a
way of making stuff extensible and the
new State memory is of course the same
shape so we just copy it it looks like I
am missing a parenthesis somewhere I
guess we'll find it when I go ahead and
run the program so oh it's not self
thought and it's it's def there we go
definite perfect so we'll also need an
action memory and that of course will
also be an array of zeros in the shape
of size by number of actions I believe
that means I need an extra bread the
scene there yes and we'll also have a
reward memory
and that will just be in shape mm sighs
we also need a terminal memory so in
reinforcement learning we have the
concept of the terminal state so when
the episode is over the agent enters the
terminal state from which it receives no
future rewards so the value of that
terminal State is identically zero and
so the way we're going to keep track of
when we transition into terminal States
is by saving the done flags from the
open AI gym environment and that'll be
shape numpy by zeros mmm sighs and I've
called this float32 it's probably
because torch is a little bit particular
with data types so we have to be
cognizant of that we need a function to
store transitions which is just a state
action reward new state and done flag so
the index is going to be the first
available position so mem counter just
keeps track of the last memory you
stored it's just an integer quantity
from 0 up to mem sighs and so when mem
counter becomes greater than men's size
it just wraps around from zero so when
they're equal to zero and when it's
equal to mmm sighs plus one it becomes
one and so on and so forth so state
memory sub index equals state action
memory index
reward equals state underscore and the
terminal memory good grief
terminal memory index doesn't equal done
but it equals one - done
so the reason is that when we get to the
update equation the bellman equation for
our learning function you'll see we want
to multiply by whether or not the
episode is over and that gets is
facilitated by 1 minus the quantity done
just incrementer and next we need to
sample that buffer so sample buffer and
that will take in a batch size as input
so the max memory is going to be the
minimum of either mem counter or mem
size not the max but the minimum then
match is just going to be a random
choice of maximum index of maximum
number of elements excuse me equal to
batch size scroll down a bit and then we
want to get ahold of the respective
states actions rewards and new states
and terminal flags and pass them back to
the learning function sub batch new
states
rewards you know it's not easy to type
and talk at the same time apparently and
let's get actions self dot action memory
fetch and terminal
good grief so we want to return States
actions
rewards new states and the terminal
flags perfect so that is it for our
replay memories so you're gonna see this
a lot in the other videos on deep
deterministic policy gradients because
we're gonna need it for basically
anything that uses a memory next let's
go ahead and get to the meat of the
problem with our critic Network and as
is often the case when you're dealing
with PI torch you want to derive your
neural network classes from n n dot
module that gives you access to
important stuff like the Train and eval
function which will set us in train or
evaluation mode very important later I
couldn't get it to work until I figure
that out so a little tidbit for you you
also need access to the parameters for
updating the weights of the neural
network so let's define our initialize
function the beta is our learning rate
we'll need input dims number of
dimensions for the first fully connected
layer as well as second connected layer
number of actions a name the name is
important for saving the network you'll
see that we have many different networks
so we'll want to keep track of which one
is which very important as well as I
checkpoint directory for saving the
model they're also very important as
this model runs very very slowly so
you'll want to us save it periodically
and you want to call the super
constructor for critic Network and that
will call the constructor friend dot
module I believe input dims equals input
dims I see one dims so these would just
be the parameters for our deep neural
network that approximates the value
function the number of actions a
checkpoint file and that is OS path join
checkpoint der with name plus underscore
DD PG and if you check my github repo I
will upload the train model because this
model takes a long time to train so I
want you to be able to take advantage of
the fully trading model that I've spent
the resources in time training up so you
may as well benefit from that so next up
we need to define the first layer of our
neural network just a linear layer and
that'll take input dims and output F c1
dims we're also going to need a number
for initializing the weights and biases
of that layer of the neural network
we're going to call that f1 and it's
divided by 1 over the square root of the
number of dimensions into the network so
self dot FC 1 dot weight a data dot size
and that returns a tuple so I need the
zeroth element of that and then we want
to initialize that layer by using T
torch and in an it uniform underscore
the tensor you want to initialize which
is FC 1 weight data up from minus 1 to
positive 1 so this will be a small
number of order point 1 or so not
exactly 0.1 but of order point 1 and you
also want to initialize the biases by
Assad data and that gets the same number
and again in the future video when we go
over the derivation of the paper I'll
explain all of this but just for now
know that this is too
constrain the initial weights of the
network to a very narrow region of
parameter space to help you get better
convergence perfect so oh and make sure
to subscribe so you don't miss that
video because it's gonna be lit so bn1
is a layered norm and takes FC one dims
as input The Bachelor Malaysian helps
with convergence of your model you don't
get good convergence if you don't have
it so leave it in so FC 2 is a second
layer another linear it takes FC 1 dims
as input and outputs FC 2 dims good
grief
and we want to do the same thing with
initialization so it's 1 over the square
root of self FC 2 wait data dot size 0
and you want to do T and n in that
uniform underscore C to wait data minus
f2 up to F to make sure that's right so
we don't screw that up because that's
important that looks correct the syntax
here is the first parameter is a tensor
you want to initialize and then the
lower and upper boundaries so next we
need B n 2 which is our second batch
normal layer FC 2 dims and just a note
the fact that we have a normalization
layer a bachelor type layer means that
we have to use the eval and trained
functions later kind of a nuisance it
took me a while to figure that out
the critic network is also going to get
a action value because the action value
function takes in the states and actions
as input but we're gonna add it in at
the very end of the network linear
actions see two dims and this gets a
constant initialization of zero zero
three or a sorry the the next one the
output gets a initialization of zero
zero three and since this is a scalar
value it just has one output and you
want to initialize it again uniformly
not cute at weight data and that gets
minus F 3 up to F 3 and likewise for
bias data okay so now we have our
optimizer and that will be the atom
optimizer and what are we going to
optimize the parameters and the learning
rate will be beta so you notice that we
did not define parameters right here
right we're just calling it and this
comes from the inheritance from n n dot
module and that's why we do that so we
get access to the network parameters
next you certainly want to run this on a
GPU because it is an incredibly
expensive algorithm so you want to call
the device so T dot device CUDA 0 if T
CUDA is available else CUDA 1 so I have
two GPUs if you only have a single GPU
it will be else CPU but I don't
recommend running this on a CPU so next
you want to send the whole network to
your device by self dot to self dot
device we are almost there for the
critic class next thing we have to worry
about is the forward function and that
takes a state and an ax
as input keep in mind the actions are
continuous so it's a vector in this case
length two for the continuous lunar
lander environment it's two real numbers
in a list or numpy array format so state
value its FC one state and then you want
to pass it through B and one state value
and finally you want to activate it if
that value state value now it is an open
debate whether or not you want to do the
value before or after the batch
normalization in my mind it makes more
sense to do the batch normalization
first because when you are calculating
batch statistics if you apply the value
first then your lopping off everything
below zero right so that means that your
statistics going to be skewed toward the
positive end when perhaps the real
distribution has a mean of zero instead
of a positive mean or maybe it even has
a negative mean which you wouldn't see
if you used the value function before
the batch normalization so just
something to keep in mind you can play
around with it feel free to clone this
and see what you get but that's how I've
done it
I did try both ways and this seemed to
work the best so next we want to feed it
into the second fully connected layer BN
to state value and then we want to be
into that sorry I already did that one
second let the cat out so we've already
done the bachelor Malaysian we don't
want to activate it yet what we want to
do first is taking account of the action
value and what we're going to do is
activate the action through the action
value layer and perform a value
activation on it right away
we're not going to calculate bash
statistics on this so we don't need to
worry about that but what we want to do
is add the two values together so state
action value F dot rel you Teta add
state value
action value other thing that's a little
bit wonky here and I invite you to clone
this and play with yourself is that I am
double rel Ewing the action value
function so the action value quantity so
I do a value here and then I do a rel
you on the add now this is a little bit
sketchy I've played around with it and
this is the way it works for me so if
you can clone it and get it to work a
different way the other possibility is
that you don't do this value here but
you do the value after the add so value
is a non commutative function with ADD
so what that means is that if you do an
addition first and then a rally that's
different than doing the sum of the two
values right or so if you take value of
minus ten plus value of five you get a
value of minus 10 of zero plus value of
five is five so you get five if you take
the value of minus ten plus five then
you get a RAL U of minus five or zero so
it's a non commutative function so it
does matter the order but this is the
way I found it to work I've seen other
implementations that do it differently
feel free to clone this and do your own
thing with it I welcome any additions
improvements or comments so then we want
to get the actual state action value by
passing that's additive quantity through
our final layer of the network and go
ahead and return that a little bit of
bookkeeping we have a check save check
point function and just save print
and then you want to call T dot save
self dot state dict what this does is it
creates a state dictionary where the
keys are the names of the parameters and
the values are the parameters themselves
and where do you want to save that you
want to say that in the checkpoint file
then you also have the load checkpoint
good grief checkpoint function and that
does the same thing just in Reverse
loading checkpoint and you want self dot
load State dict T download self dot
checkpoint file so that is it for our
critic Network now we move on to the
actor network then of course derives
from an N dot module we have an init
function takes alpha if we get spelled
correctly input dins FC one dims FC two
dims this is pretty similar to the
critic network it will just have a
different structure in particular we
don't have the we don't have the actions
I can't type and talk at the same time
but it's pretty similar nonetheless so
input dims we want to save
and actions see one dims fc2 dims same
deal let me go copy the checkpoint file
function just to make life easy perfect
I like to make life easy so we have our
first fully connected layer and in doubt
linear take self dot input dims as input
and FC one dims and of course it
operates in the same way as I discussed
in the replay buffer where it will just
unpack the tuple next we have the
initialization by a very similar one
over NP square root self-taught FC one
that weight data size zeroth element and
we want to initialize the first layer
uniformly within that interval in its
uniform underscore s you want to weight
data minus F 1 and F 1 copy that that
will be FC 1 bias data FC 2 is another
linear layer takes FC 1 dims as inputs
and outputs FC 2 dims as you might
expect and the initialization for that
will be basically the same thing except
for layered two so FC 2 weight data and
then you know what let's just copy this
paste and make sure we don't mess it up
FC 2 F 2 whoo good grief and plus minus
F 2 and that is all well and good other
thing we forgot is the batch norm and
that is an N layer norm and that takes
FC 1 dims as input
likewise for layer two that is another
layer norm takes FC two dims as input
shape and that doesn't get initialized
but we do have the f3 and that is zero
zero three this comes from the paper
we'll go over this in a future video but
don't worry about it self thought mu mu
is the representation of the policy in
this case it is a real vector of shape
and actions it's the actual action not
the probability right because this is
deterministic so it's just a linear
layer takes FC two dims as input and
outputs the number of actions and we
want to do the same thing where we
initialize the weights let's copy-paste
and instead of FC two it will be mu and
a set of f2 it is f3 as you might expect
am I forgetting anything I don't believe
so
so finally we have an optimizer and
that's again optimum self dot parameters
and learning rate equals alpha we also
want to do the same thing with the
device t dot device CUDA 0 if T dot CUDA
is available else CPU and finally send
it to the device that is that so next we
have the feed forward so that takes the
state as input so I'm just gonna call it
X this is bad naming don't ever do this
self dot F c1 do as I say not as I do
self dot be in one of state
value of X that's a mistake should be X
X equals self dot FC 2 of X B into X and
then X equal T tan hyperbolic self that
Mew of X and then return X so what this
will do is pass the current state or
whatever state or set of states batch in
this case you want to look at perform
the first feed forward pass batch
Norment value
send it through the second layer and
batch norm but not activate send it
through to the final layer now I take
that back I do want to activate that
silly mean if thought well you X and
then it will pass it through the final
layer Mew and perform a tangent
hyperbolic activation so what that will
do is it'll bound it between minus 1 and
plus 1 and that's important for many
environments later on we can multiply it
by the actual action bounds so some
environments have a max action of plus
minus 2 so if you're bounding it by plus
or minus 1 that's not going to be very
effective so you just have a
multiplicative factor later on and then
I'm gonna go copy the to save and load
checkpoint functions because those are
precisely the same that's it for our
actor next we come to our final class
the meat of the problem the agent and
that just gets derived from the base
object and that gets a whole bunch of
parameters alpha and beta of course you
need to pass in learning rates for the
actor and critic networks input dims a
quantity called tau I haven't introduced
that yet but we'll get to it in a few
minutes we're gonna pass in the
environment that's to get the action
space that I talked about just a second
ago the gamma which is the agents
discount factor so if you're not
familiar of reinforcement learning and
agent values are reward now more than in
values or reward in the future because
there's uncertainty around future
rewards so it makes no sense to value it
as much as a current reward so what's
the discount factor you know how much
less does it value if you reward 1%
that's where we get a gamma of 0.99
it's a hyper parameter you can play
around with it values like 0.95 all the
way up to 0.99 our typical number of
actions will default it to to a lot of
environments only have two actions the
max size of our memory that gets 1
million one one two three one through
three layer one size equals default of
400 there are two size 300 is our
default and again that comes from the
paper and a batch size for our batch
learning from our replay memory so you
want to go ahead and save the parameters
equal towel and you want to instantiate
a memory that's a replay buffer of size
max size input dims and end actions we
also want to store the batch size for
our learning function we want to
instantiate our first actor yes there
are more than one and that gets alpha
input dims layer one size layer to size
and actions equals and actions name
equals actor so let's copy that so next
we have our target actor so much like
the deep queue Network algorithm this
uses target networks as well as the base
network so it's an off policy method and
the difference here is this going to be
called target actor
it'll be otherwise identical this will
allow us to have multiple different
agents with similar names and you'll see
how that plays into it momentarily we
also need a critic that's a critic
network takes beta input dims
they are one size higher to size and
actions equals and actions name equals
critic so let's be nice and tidy there
and we also have a target critic as well
and that is otherwise identical it just
gets a different name and this is very
similar to q-learning where you have Q
eval and Q next or Q target whatever you
want to call it same concept
okay so those are all of our networks
what else we need we need noise and
that's our oh you action noise and the
MU is just going to be numpy zeroes of
shape and actions so it'll give you an
array of zeros this is the mean of the
rewards over time and next we need
another function you may be able to
predict if you've seen my videos on Q
learning we should check out is the
update network parameters and we'll call
it with an initial value I equals 1 so
what this does is it solves a problem of
a moving target so in Q learning if you
use one network to calculate both the
action as well as the value of that
action then you're really chasing a
moving target because you're updating
that estimate every turn right so you
are end up using the same parameter for
both and it can lead to divergence so
the solution to that is to use a target
network that learns the values of these
states and action combinations and then
the other network is what learns the
policy and then of course periodically
you have to overwrite the target
parameter target networks parameters
with the evaluation that where
parameters and this function will do
precisely that except that we have four
networks instead of two so next we want
to choose an action
and that takes whatever the current
observation of the environment is now
very very important you have to put the
actor into evaluation mode now this
doesn't perform an evaluation step this
just tells PI torch that you don't want
to calculate statistics for the batch
normalization and this is very critical
if you don't do this the agent will not
learn and it doesn't do what you think
the name implies it would do write the
corresponding the complementary function
is trained it doesn't perform a training
set that puts it in training mode where
it does store those statistics in the
graph for the batch normalization if you
don't do batch norm then you don't need
to do this but if you do what's the
other function drop out drop out does
the same thing or has the same tick
where you have to call the eval and
train functions so let's start by
putting our observation into a tensor do
you tie because T dot float to self
actor device so that'll turn it into a
CUDA float tensor now you want to get
the actual action from the in the actor
network so feed that forward to self dot
actor dot device and this makes sure
that you send it to the device so it's a
CUDA tenser so mu prime is going to be
mu plus T dot tensor what are we going
to use self that noise that'll give us
our exploration noise and that is going
to be D type of float and we will send
that to actor device and then you want
to say should be actor dot train
shouldn't ya self dot actor dot train
yes and then you want to return mu Prime
now CPU detach numpy so this is an idiom
within pi torch where you have to
basically do this otherwise it doesn't
it doesn't doesn't give you the actual
number you write it's gonna try to pass
out a tensor which doesn't work because
you can't pass a tensor into the open a
gym so
kind of a funny little quirk but it is
necessary so now we need a function to
store state transitions and this is just
kind of an interface for our replay
memory class so memory store transition
state action reward new state done
simple so now we come to the meat of the
problem where we actually be learning so
you don't want to learn if you haven't
filled up at least batch size of your
memory buffers so self dot memory mem
counter is less than self that batch
size then you just want to return
otherwise action reward new state done
you want to sample your memory memory
dot sample buffer self that batch size
then you want to go ahead and turn all
of those into tensors that's because
they come back as an umpire raised in
this case we'll put them on the critic
device as long as around the same device
it doesn't matter I do this for
consistency because these values will be
used in the critic Network so the Dunn's
equal Tita tensor done to self critic
device you need the new state P that
tensor new state D type T float to self
critic device you also need the actions
predict out device and you need states
that tensor device and now we come to
another quirk of Pi torch where we're
going to have to send everything to eval
mode for the targets it may not be that
important I did it for consistency so we
want to calculate the target actions
much like you do in the bellman equation
for Q learning deep Q learning target
actor for word new state you want the
critic value underscore which is the new
states so the target critic dot forward
and that takes target actions as input
so what we're doing is getting the
target actions from the target actor
Network in other words what actions it
should it take based on the target
actors estimates and then plugging that
into the state value function for the
target critic network you also want the
critic value which is self dot critic
dot forward for state and action so in
other words what was the what is your
estimate of the values of the states and
actions we actually encountered in our
subset of the replay buffer so now we
have to calculate the targets that we're
going to move towards or J in range self
that batch size and I use a loop instead
of a vectorized implementation because
the vectorizing implementation is a
little bit tricky if you don't do it
properly you can end up with something
of shape batch size by batch size which
won't flag an error but it definitely
gives you the wrong answer and you don't
get learning so target dot append
reward sub J + self dot gamma x critic
Bayou underscore sub J times done sub J
so this is where I was talking about the
done flags
if the episode is over then the value of
the resulting state is multiplied by
zero and so you don't take it into
account you only take into account the
reward from the current state precisely
as one would want so now let's go ahead
and turn that target into a tensor sorry
tensor target not to self critic dot
device and we want to reshape this
target egos target dot view cell top
batch size and one now now we can come
to the calculation of the loss functions
so we want to set the critic back into
training mode because we have already
performed the evaluation now we want to
actually calculate the values for batch
normalization a train
so about critic dot optimizer zero grad
in PI torch whenever you calculate the
loss function you want to zero your
gradients that's so that gradients from
previous steps don't accumulate and
interfere with the calculation it can
slow stuff down you don't want that so
critical loss is just good grief f dot
MSE means square error loss between the
target and the critic value so then you
want to back propagate back propagate
that backward and step your optimizer
boom so that's it for the critic so now
we want to set the critic into
evaluation mode for the calculation of
the loss for our actor network so how
about actor dot optimizer 0 grad and I
apologize that this is confusing it was
confusing to me it took me a while to
figure it out this is one of the ways in
which tensorflow is superior to PI torch
you don't have this quirk I tend to like
tensor flow a little bit better but you
know whatever
well we'll just figure it out man and
get it going so mu equals the for
propagation of the state I'm gonna put
the actor into training mode and you
want to calculate your actor loss that's
just minus self dot critic dot forward
state state and mu after loss equals T
dot mean of actor loss again stay tuned
for the derivation from the paper this
is all outlined there otherwise it seems
mysterious but this video is already 45
minutes long so you know that ought to
wait for a future video after loss
backward and self dot actor dot
optimizer dot step and then we're done
learning so now after you finish
learning you want to update the network
parameters for your target actor and
target critic networks so self taught
update network parameters whew man ok so
we're almost there I promise
let's go ahead and do that def update
network parameters self and tau equals
none by default so tau is a parameter
that allows the update of the target
network to gradually approach the
evaluation networks and this is
important for a nice slow convergence
you don't want to take two largest steps
in between updates so tau is a small
number much much less than one so
so if tau is none then you want to say
tau equals self dot tau now this may
seem mysterious the reason I'm doing
this is because at the very beginning
when we call the initializer we say
update network parameters tau equals 1
this is because in that in the very
beginning we want to update or sorry we
want all the networks to start with the
same weights and so we call it with a
towel of 1 and in that case tau is not
none so tau is just 1 and you will get
the update rule here in a second so this
is more hocus-pocus with PI torch actor
named parameters so this will do is
it'll get all the names of the
parameters from these networks and we
want to do the same thing for target
actor parameters target critic params
okay now that we have the parameters
let's turn them into a dictionary that
makes iterating them much easier because
this is actually a generator so I
believe don't quote me on that
critic Graham's
the actor estate dict equals dict of the
actor programs target critic state
militias to target critic dict
people's dict Rams cramps boom okay
almost there so now we want to iterate
over these dictionaries and copy
parameters so for name in critic state
dict critic state dict
sub name equals equals tau times critic
state dict name dot clone plus one minus
tau times target critic dict name dot
clone cell the target critic a load
state dict critic state dict so what
this does is it iterates over this
dictionary looks at the key in the in
the in the dictionary and updates the
values from this particular network and
you can see that when tau is 1 you get 1
minus 1 is 0 so it's just this equals
tau 1 times that so as I did the
identity and then it loads the target
critic with that parameter so at the
very beginning it'll load it with the
parameters from the initial critic
network and likewise for the Patra
network so let's go ahead and copy this
and just go ahead and change critic to
actor and then we'll be done with that
function and we'll only have one other
thing to take care of before we get to
the main program target actor
actor state dict I believe that is it
yes indeed it is now there should be
target actor yes perfect
okay now it's right so next up we have
two other bookkeeping functions to save
the models so def save models and you
definitely want this because this thing
takes forever to train and self-taught
critic and target actor and target
critic and load models does the inverse
operation yeah just copy all this load
keep things simple right and again I
will upload since this takes so long I'm
going to upload my saved model
parameters to the get up for you
but this is it this is 275 lines so this
is probably the longest project we have
worked on here had machine learning with
fill if you made it this far
congratulations we're already 50 minutes
in and we're almost done I promise so
let's come over to our main function and
we want to import our agent
so DDP G torch import agent we want to
import Djinn we want to do we want yes
we want numpy we want my SuperDuper
awesome import plot learning function
and that is it so env Jim make lunar
lander Conte in US v to agent equals
agent alpha zero point one two three
four to five so two point five by ten to
the minus five beta equals zero point
zero zero zero to five so two point five
by ten to the minus four input dims
equals a list with element eight town
zero point zero zero one and V equals E
and B well that reminds me I didn't
multiply by the action space high in the
function for the choose action
don't worry that'll be in the potential
implementation or I can leave it as an
exercise to the reader it doesn't matter
for this environment when we get to
other ones that word doesn't matter I'll
be a little bit more diligent about that
that size is 64 size 400 and r2 size 300
and actions plus two now another
interesting tidbit is that we have to
set the random C this is not something
I've done before but this is a highly
sensitive learning method so if you read
the original paper they do averages over
five runs and that's because every run
is a little bit different and I suspect
that's why they had to initialize the
weights and biases within such a narrow
range right you don't want to go away
from plus and minus one when you can
constrain to something much more narrow
it gives you little bit more
repeatability
so we have to set the numpy random seed
to some value instead of none so in this
case I've used zero I've seen other
values used please clone this and see
what happens if you input other seed
values so next we need a score history
to keep track of the scores over time
and we need to
iterate over a thousand games done
equals false score equals zero
observation equals E and V dot reset I
got a new observation so while not done
agent dot choose action Bob's new state
reward done info equals e and we got
step act agent dot remember we want to
keep track of that transition Hobbs Act
reward new States int done agent learn
we learn on every step because this is a
temporal difference learning method
instead of a Monte Carlo type method
where we would learn at the end of every
episode keep track of the score and set
your old state to the new state so at
the end of the episode if at the end of
every episode I want to print print the
place marker so we'll say score history
dot append score print episode I score
sent up to F score 100 game average %
dot 2f and what this will do is take the
last 100 games and compute the mean so
that way you can get an idea vast
learning remember with the luminol an
environment salt means that it has
gotten ace an average score of 1 200
over the last 100 games so every 25
games we want to save the model agent
save models and at the end file name
equals lunar lander PNG that's not on
the loop you want to do at the end of
all the loop game's plot learning I'll
name
no score history
file name in a window of 100 games Wow
so an hour in we finally finished this
now we get to go to the terminal and see
how many typos I made I'm sure there's
probably 50 so let's get to it alright
so here we are let's see what we get you
want to run torch Lunar Lander fingers
crossed
okay so that's a stupid one so in line
30 we forgot an equal sign let's go back
there and fix that alright here we are
so it says line 30 yes right here all
right did we do that again anywhere else
not that I can see but that's no
guarantee alright so let's go back to
the terminal
alright let's try it again huh line 119
okay typical all right so 119 right
there so that's in the actor let's just
scroll down
that's the agent class I don't think I
did it there all right I'm going back to
the terminal
alright so I started it and it ran so
let's see built-in function has no
function or method has no attribute
numpy all right that's an interesting
bug let's fix that so that is on line
192 in our choose action function and mu
Prime oh that's why it's detached as a
function not an object I should fix it
let's head back to the terminal
rewards is not deep find so that is in
line 55 okay ah it's just called reward
there we go I had the s and back to the
terminal
ah perfect that's easy to fix
Victor temps ICD PG huh because I didn't
make the directory first that's easy
perfect now it's running so I'm not
gonna let this run all 1000 games
because it takes about a couple hours or
so instead let's take a look here so I
was running this earlier when I was
making the videos for the sorry the
recording the agents play while making
for this video and you can see that
within under 650 games it went ahead and
solved it so when you print out the
trailing average for the last hundred
games we get a reward of well over 200
now keep in mind one interesting thing
is that this is still actually in
training mode it's not excuse me it's
not in full evaluation mode because we
still have some noise right if you
wanted to do a pure evaluation of the
agent you would set the noise to zero
we'll do that in a set of future videos
so there's a whole bunch of stuff I can
do on this topic but just keep in mind
that this is an agent that is still
taking some random actions the noise is
nonzero and so it is still taking
suboptimal actions of getting a score of
260 and still beating the environment
even though that noise is present and
you can see it in like episode 626 where
it gets a score of 26 so and then in
episode 624 where it does you know eight
point five eight points so that is
pretty cool stuff so this is a very
powerful algorithm and keep in mind this
was a continuous action space totally
intractable for q-learning right that is
simply not possible
it's an infinitude of actions so you
need something like DD PG to handle this
and it handles it quite well in future
videos we're going to get to the Walker
the bipedal Walker we're gonna get to
the learning from pixels where we do the
continuous bracing environment and we'll
probably get into other stuff from the
Robo school of the open AI gym so make
sure to subscribe so that you can see
that in future videos go ahead and check
out the github for this so you can get
the weight so you can play around with
this so you don't have to spend a couple
hours training it on your GPU make sure
to leave a like share this if you found
it helpful that is incredibly helpful to
me and leave a comment down below I
answer all my questions I look forward
to seeing you all in the next video